ne l'appelez plus jamais haut de la rue
nationale le quartier va changer de nom
ce sera la porte de loire ce qui va
engendrer le premier changement de nom
de station de tramway anatole france
devient lui aussi porte de loire c'est
vraiment notre volonté de deux tournées
la ville de retourner la ville vers le
fleuve on le redécouvre avec la
guinguette avec la plage mais il est
vrai qu'il ya une certaine époque
cet emplacement de la ville était le
plus animé c'est là que se tenait les
marchés c'est là qu'il y avait la mairie
c'est là que les gens se rassembler et
donc c'est je crois très bien de renouer
avec cela en ce qui concerne les travaux
c'est toujours prévu qu'ils durent 24
mois il devait commencer après le mois
de mars et l'inauguration du ccco des
voisins il aurait pu débuter avant les
vacances d'été
pas idéal pour les touristes l'arrivée
des grues et autres pelleteuse est
maintenant prévu pour septembre
c'est que le promoteur constructeur
attend encore des contrats de
construction en particulier ceux des
deux hôtels une fois que nous aurons
contracté avec nos clients
hilton en tête nous
pourront donner un ordre de service de
travaux à l'entreprise eiffage
construction entreprise de construction
du groupe eiffage pour démarrer ses
travaux
donc voilà d'un point de vue technique
administratif nous sommes dans les clous
d'un point de vue des annonces qui
avaient été faites on aurait pu espérer
effectivement pouvoir démarrer notamment
les éléments de fondation manière
anticipée ça n'a pas été le cas du fait
notamment de ses contraintes de
signature de contrats recherches
archéologiques comprise la livraison des
bâtiments un temps prévu pour mars 2019
puis pour les grandes vacances 2019 se
tournent maintenant vers la fin d'année
2010 9 à quelques mois seulement de la
fin du mandat du maire de tours prévus
en mars 2020